oh that's this is just wrong shaq's
penis is kevin hart
speaking of coming i wanna
talk about whoa
ladies and gentlemen i will
hey that's not what i meant see y'all
mine in the gutter
i know the football team's like all
trying to recruit me and stuff and like
they were supposed to like why don't you
throw things and i was like if throwing
things but like now i totally love it i
mean watch this
[Laughter]
what sorry
is that bug fast no that's water you've
probably heard of it
who's the most famous person i've ever
met well i'm not one's medic the um
quite an impressive one i don't want to
show off but you know you know you know
no you know how villages have got idiots
yeah
i met the idiot for the whole of glasgow
[Applause]
in america they use a sugar glasses
your glasses made of spun sugar you
don't get hurt right yeah i i use the
real one
then i roll over the guy take the hammer
you know
break the window the window pang
explosion then i said ow then i'm coming
back big hole here
jackie is the nicest guy in the whole
world i wanna let y'all know that's why
those movies were so good because jackie
was so nice and i was so comfortable but
jackie would give me a gift every day
first rush hour jackie chan would give
me a gift every day i finished my
trailer yeah i'm like what is going on
he's so nice and i had to buy him
something after a while i said i gotta
get him something but then i realized
he's from china they make everything
over there he was getting it for free
anyway
hey you get your [ __ ] hands off me
brian cranston looks like jim carrey
impersonating
matthew mcconaughey
all right all right all righty then
you've done drugs with him yes i have
cocaine
right
cocaine yes alcohol
alcohol yes pills including xanax and
adderall right
um
that i'm not too sure of
okay um
where is he going
i have a son that he's older he's got to
be at least eight
and uh
but when he's first born you know it's
the most you know this the most exciting
thing
that that's ever happened to that's
right yes and uh i'll never forget it
and then six months later i went hang
gliding
way more exciting
[Laughter]
there's a scene uh where you uh pleasure
yourself uh how do you approach that
kind of scene that's got to be a strange
thing to to shoot on camera how do i
approach it mentally
or
just
[Applause]
i bet the john lithgow's ball sack looks
exactly like his face
my face is not complimented but my ball
sack is
i thought i was doing one thing and then
when i showed up it was a whole
different thing it was a full body shot
and i asked the director
so what should i do and she said
masturbate like it
says in the script
[Laughter]
what a kind directorial note oh yeah
you know meryl streep right i do she's
not nominated this year i'm sorry to
hear that she should be nominated for
walking down the street i'm sorry too so
i may i'll make her a car and i want
everybody to sign it oh that's sweet
yeah i think this is really going to
make her feel better
sign will be here so you you can feel
better it's lovely
anything you'd like to say to meryl
streep yes you're you're a loser this
year but um
but you're gonna you're gonna get them
next time g-force more like g he's fat
the only french word you know is buffet
that's not true i know the word uh
croissant i heard your last name used to
be even longer but you ate all the other
letters of the alphabet zack you look
like a homeless guy who's been to a soup
kitchen that specializes in ice cream
soup
ah what line should i do i don't know i
don't know i feel the need the need for
speed
little game that involves a female so
are you good with the ladies am i good
with the ladies am i good with the
ladies why don't you just ask mariah
pull him back
[Applause]
you don't want to be tied down you're
young you look like a young guy
19.
wow you're really young
holy [ __ ]
i didn't know 19 year olds were allowed
in here
this is crazy what
are you really 19
what are you drinking
water
damn you don't have a fake id or
anything
i guess you can't really cop to it now
but
that's are your friends all 19 too
20. all right 23. good job
that's it well done
19 when you're 19 banging a 23 year old
i'm not saying you're hooking up but
the night is young
a few more waters you don't know where
the night's gonna take you you know this
is
crazy
[Music]
i'm a
imma is that a word i might be wondering
why that woman got no titties
they're here they're here don't worry uh
i was once hit by a car while riding my
bike and the driver
was my girlfriend
and why were you riding your bike and
she was in the car because as a young
man i
fancied myself a physically fit
you wouldn't travel in other any
transportation but bicycling is there's
enough horsepower in this body to
bicycle around west newberry
i'm going to say it yeah right now yeah
1917 is not just a movie it's also the
number of times i had to pee during the
irishman yeah and you hold then you hold
like that and then you release name
something that a person might take a
picture of then post it to facebook
i'm sorry
what did you say
i say it don't i just think it you see
it
well that would be
a much more metaphysical game
okay
girls take pictures of boobs
yeah let's go to the board
[Applause]
themselves themselves
[Applause]
of all the questions we had
the one that came up most often
was asked benedict to say the word
penguin
what is this about well apparently i got
it wrong repeatedly in the documentary
and now i'm completely terrified of the
word um i don't go near it the first one
you sort of get away with and then after
that you lose all sense of what it is
let's let's have a look listen carefully
and the last thing you might expect to
see here
[Music]
is penguins these are fjordland crested
penguins named after this corner of
south new zealand
so why are these woodlands so attractive
to penguins
a fresh water stream through the forest
makes a handy highway for a parent
penguin heading home from the fishing
tree